MARTINA BALAGOVIC: Welcome.
Today's problem actually
appeared in a quiz.
It appeared in quiz one in
fall of 1999 as question four.
The problem puts the usual solve
the following system upside
down by saying we have some
matrix and we know that all
the solutions to A*x equals
this vector here, [1, 4, 1, 1],
all the solutions to this
problem are given by x equals
[0, 1, 1] plus any
number c times [1, 2, 1].
And we're asked
to say everything
that we can about the
columns of the matrix A.
So I'm going to let you pretend
that you are on an exam,
try to solve it yourself,
and then come back
and compare your
solution with mine.
OK, welcome back.
So the first thing
that you should
think about in this
sort of situation
is what is the size of A?
Well, we want to multiply A with
an x that has three entries,
so A should have three columns.
Let me call those columns
c_1, c_2, and c_3.
And when I take some linear
combinations of c_1, c_2
and c_3, I'm going to get this
vector here, [1, 4, 1, 1].
So all the c_i's, c_1, c_2,
and c_3 are vectors in R_4.
Now, if you know
about, if you learned
about particular solutions
and special solutions, then
my notation here
shouldn't surprise you.
I'm going to call
this vector here x_p,
and this vector here x_s.
And I'm going to
use the fact that
x_p plus c times x_s
satisfies A times this
equals b-- I will call this
vector b-- for any number c.
In particular, what
I'm going to conclude
is that when c equals 0 we
get A times x_p equals b.
But also that when
c equals 1, we
get A times x_p plus
A times x_s equals b.
Replacing this by b, we
get that this implies
that A times x_s equals 0.
So in trying to find
what are the columns
c_1, c_2, and c_3 of the matrix
A, let's look at these two
equations.
x_p satisfies A
times x_p equals b,
and x_s satisfies A
times x_s equals 0.
Again, if you know what
particular and special
solutions are this
shouldn't surprise you.
But we also know
what x_p and x_s are,
so let's use them to try to
calculate c_1, c_2, and c_3.
A times x_p equals b means that
the linear combination of c_1,
c_2, and c_3 encoded in the
vector x_p, which is [0, 1, 1],
gives the vector b.
So c_1, c_2, c_3 times
[0, 1, 1] gives us [1, 4, 1, 1].
In other words, c_2
plus c_3 equal b.
Let's turn our attention
to A times x_s equals 0.
This says that c_1,
c_2, c_3 times--
x_s was defined to be
[0, 2,  1]-- equals 0.
In other words, 2 times
c_2 plus c_3 equals 0.
Now solving this system where
the unknowns are vectors
but it's still just a
linear system, we can see,
for example, from the second
equation that c_3 equals minus
2*c_2.
And plugging it back into
the original equation,
getting c_2 minus
2*c_2 equals b,
from which it follows that
c_2 is equal to minus b,
and that c3 is
equal to 2 times b.
So from this tiny
amount of information--
we just knew the solutions to
this one particular equation
involving A-- we got
the second column of A
and the third column of
A completely explicitly
calculated.
Now, what can we say
about the first column?
I said before that all the
solutions of A*x equals b are
of the form a particular
solution plus some number times
a special solution.
And the information that we have
is that there's just one number
here.
So we said everything, once
we remove this vector here,
everything that we get here
will satisfy A times x equals 0.
And the fact that
everything that
satisfies A times x equals 0 is
a multiple of this one vector
that was given to us means
that the null space of A
has dimension one.
There is just one
special solution.
So dimension of the
null space of A is 1.
So rank of A is the
number of columns
minus this dimension of null
space, and it's equal to 2.
As rank of A is equal
to 2, the number
of linearly independent
columns needs to be 2 as well.
So the only thing that
we can say at this point
is if the first column
was also a multiple of b,
as the second and the third are,
then the rank would be smaller
than 2.
So that is the only
thing that cannot happen.
So c_1 is not a multiple of b.
Not any multiple, including
not a zero multiple.
And that's pretty much
everything we can say.
Yes, if it was some
other multiple of it,
then we would be able to
find some other vector here
and we would have
two parameters.
But it's not, and
this is everything
that we can say about it.